first I want to start off by thanking
you for the beheading with the figure
skating in your skate because I I was a
figure skater when I was younger and so
this was like my childhood dream come
true seeing somebody beheaded with one
miracle I adore you for that being your
person up like that's so funny I think
it's a little intense I'm like like we
did that like so like a kind of a lot
guys but it's ridiculous it's hysterical
I the first thing I said to my husband
when I came home was oh my God they
killed somebody with a baby I love it
this is like my every childhood dream
come true finally
you probably if you like as a figure
skater you probably had had enough of a
lot of people and you were like I'll
just use my skate
oh my gosh so much and those things get
sharp too people don't realize this
it's true
so can you talk a little bit about like
what was your role as the producer on
Violet night like what did you do yeah I
mean like all the project at 87 North I
sort of you know with my team of
Executives we sort of find them
um we sort of developed them then we get
the cast attached and then you know I
mean David and I are definitely on set
for the things we produce almost as much
as we're on set for the things that he
directs and I produce with him
um and so you know it was it was all in
um you know which I think is part of uh
I think we we are a little bit
micromanagerial in the sense that we
have a brand that's kind of bigger than
the project in a sense and um we kind of
need to be in there uh whether we like
it or not trying to help make sure that
that whatever is has our label on it
feels a lot like one of our movies can
you talk a little bit about where the
idea for the movie came came from yeah I
mean Pat and Josh the writers
um actually have had this idea since
high school and
um they funny enough they used to do
sort of like one of those like
um kids club video things that had a
broadcasting at their school they went
to school together and they had done a
sketch about this back then like and
then they came to us and you know we're
like what do you think about this and
it's just like oh my God that's
absolutely genius and we have to do it
right now and then fortunately Universal
saw how special it could be as well and
so we feel really lucky that we got the
chance it's pretty crazy it's kind of
Gonzo you got to kind of like Buy in you
know so it totally is yeah we feel
really lucky that um that that all
happened that way
it's really gory and really violent it
lives up to its name
um but it's not quite it's not really a
horror movie it doesn't have that horror
movie vibe to it
um why did you decide or why did they
decide not to go that route I kind of
stick with more of an action comedy
route it was never intended to be horror
um it was always going to be action
comedy and it is action comedy with a
couple of like shocking on moments you
know um which I think is part of what
makes great action sometimes too is the
surprise that's just kind of similar to
horror
um I think you know if there's any sort
of like Whisper of horror it actually
comes from Tommy warkola the director we
decided to attach to the project who you
know is known a lot for some of his more
horror um space although he's done just
action and action comedy is an action
drama as well
um and so he ended up being kind of the
perfect
director her because he was ready for
the big
um but could sort of like you know land
the heart as well
um so if there's any Whispers of horror
it's probably coming from him
how did you decide to attach him to the
project he's been an old friend for a
long time funny enough
um you know we are huge fans of his dead
snow and we've actually helped him with
some of that stuff just suggesting an
action
um coordinator director you know some
for that sort of stuff
um but he and he directed a movie called
Hansel and Gretel for Paramount several
years ago and David was his second unit
director before David was a director and
they really clicked and
um uh David was sort of more experienced
with bigger Studio movies and kind of
helped guide
um Tommy in what was a you know sort of
tougher sort of
um experience with the studio and um
they became really close friends and
we've been wanting to do something with
them for a long time so then he recently
did this trip called or this um movie
called the trip in his in Norway and um
it was just this perfect
um project that uh really articulated
sort of where he's at that he can you
know it's so great if you haven't seen
it it's a great movie but it's got a lot
of Comedy to it it's a dark comedy and a
lot of great the small action and so
that ended up being a great calling card
for us to be able to say let's put them
into
um let's put him into violent night and
he um and he got the job so I know that
you were on the set for the Fall Guy
when you came away to to take this
interview
um what can you tell us about the Fall
Guy it's awesome no
um we are having an absolute blast our
full cast is here now and
um we are in full on and um I just am so
in awe of Ryan Gosling and Emily Blunt
and Winston Duke and Hannah waddingham
and I just feel so lucky and Stephanie
jazoo and I just feel so lucky that we
ended up with such an extraordinary cast
and like incredible actors and you know
it's um
it's gonna feel a lot like an 87 North
picture and a lot like David Leach movie
um you know original uh wildly inventive
and um emotionally impactful and I'm
just really really excited about it
already cool
um so what about it excites you
the most
um uh honestly it you know it's Dave
David coming from stunts and telling a
story about a stunt man who you know is
coming into his own
um through having to investigate you
know a crime is
um incredibly special in the sense that
we get to do
um we're really trying to do a lot of
practical action on this we always do
but in this case it's really big
practical action and
um and it just feels like um you know
we're playing paying homage to the stunt
community and to really Cinema and the
those of us who make the movies
um and it's sort of a love letter to the
industry and um you know and on top of
it just being really fun and um and you
know and and um and what I think will be
a really good time for for the audience
and I know it's based on a 1980s Series
where were you a fan of the series
um I'm not that familiar with the series
but it is a series that goes I've gotten
to know since I um have been on the
project but um it is
um definitely a series that a lot of
stunt men became stunt men because of so
and they did phenomenal action for the
time the
um practical action weirdly doesn't
really happen in television shows
anymore but back then they were doing
incredible stunts on the show every day
and um so it's pretty cool to have that
as our sort of you know like trying to
pay homage to that I should say are all
of the stents then going to be practical
in the film
you can never say all my friend uh okay
all of them will have elements of
practical and a lot of them will be ABS
100 practical in fact our special our
visual effects guys are like
um you know happy and sad that their
jobs are really marginalized on this one
because these days visual effects is
really King you know so they're sort of
like this is amazing and what's my job
what's my role because you guys are
doing so much in camera so that's where
we want to be um and that's really
exciting
um and so what else are you working on
um we're working on a lot of Originals
right now
um we are also working on a nobody too
um we're hoping to start working on a
violent night too
um if everything goes well the next few
weeks
um you know we are
um you know we have a tendency to just
kind of keep our heads down and and
focus you know on on sort of what's in
front of us or are near
um so yeah that's kind of it you know
um we're just really we're in it we
still have three two and a half months
of um work to do on this one how far are
you in the process of nobody too
um we hope to make it next year so
fingers crossed so our theory is you
don't need to make a sequel just to make
a sequel we need to make a great Sequel
and so it's about making sure that we
get it right and if we do I think
there's a lot of hope that
um we can go next year well thank you so
much I think that's all I've got for you
but thank you pleasure talking to you
nice talking to you too